hello everyone I'm Peter Bauer and
welcome to Pete's lab today we will
continue our series of short lectures or
vignettes on specific subjects related
to groundwater in brown fields and today
we're going to discuss sediment size
class' and sieve mesh openings please
get your handout sub mesh openings and
sediment size class ready so you can
follow along and also watch the
demonstration if you do not have a
handout please pause the video and go to
our website and print out the handout
this lecture on submission and sediment
size class falls under a larger subject
heading that we might call particles
particles are just pieces of matter of
chunks of matter that we find in the
environment and the particles we have in
front of us today we have pieces of
stone and Rock what we might call mud or
sand there are many words we can use to
describe particles mud sand gravel dirt
sediment alluvium loose and so forth
many many different terms but they all
are categories of the overarching
subject called particles we have a word
for this
in geology called regolith our ATOL ith
lift of course comes from the greek root
lithos meaning stone and Griego comes
from also another Greek word for blanket
so these are the unconsolidated loose
material particles that blanket the
surface of the earth one of the most
important things that one can do and
when we're looking at these particles
understanding how they move and are
shaped in the environment is to analyze
their sizes
and the sins that we have here allow us
to do just that at least for certain
sizes of particles sieve mesh openings
are seen here you can see that the mesh
is really a kind of window screen a very
finely woven stainless steel grid and
each of those openings is machined to
very precise tolerances so that you will
see on your handout the US US standard
sieve mesh numbers and the next column
which says opening in millimeters our
sieve and there are many many different
sizes of sins and our sins have been
very carefully selected to correspond to
some very important things that we'll
talk about in a second but if you look
at the front of this you'll see that we
have the number 10 the number 18 the
number 35 the number 60 the number 120
and the 230 mesh sieve and then a pan at
a pan at the bottom now let's talk about
each of these specifically the number 10
mesh sieve which we see here has an
opening of two millimeters you'll also
notice on your handout along the left
hand column a ruler showing numbered
centimeters and then of course each of
those centimeters divided into ten
millimeters so here we have a 2
millimeter opening the number 18 mesh
sieve finer has a 1 millimeter
opening and we'll begin to see now as we
go to the 35 mesh sieve that the
openings are decreasing by a factor of
two each being one half the size of the
previous one so here we are the number
three
five nests Civet point five millimeters
will also now see the 60 mesh sieve 0.25
millimeters 120 mesh sieve very fine
screen perhaps you can see me through
the screen point one two five
millimeters this is about the thickness
of a human hair 125 micro meters 0.125
millimeters and the 230 mesh sieve is at
point zero six to five millimeters these
numbers SIVs correspond to some very
important sediment size classes for
instance we take the number two
millimeter of the number 10 Master sieve
with two millimeter openings we see that
it sits exactly at the boundary between
what we call gravel and sand so that if
we pour particles in here of course and
shake it the larger particles will
remain on top and all of those would be
gravel anything that comes through would
be sand or mud let's stop for a second
and talk a little bit about gravel
granules of course by reading the chart
you can see are bigger than two
millimeters but smaller than four
millimeters in size way down at the
bottom of your ruler I have some
granules here two to four millimeters
next we can see that pebbles are from
four to sixty four millimeters and I'm
going to mark this on the chart so you
can see the range of sizes and I have
here a fairly small pebble and some
successively larger ones with this
pebble being about the biggest that you
could get so pebbles are good for
throwing the next size
is from 64 millimeters to 256
millimeters and these are called cobbles
and I will mark that on here so bigger
than 64 that is bigger than about that
width and smaller than 256 millimeters
here for instance I have well a
cobblestone and cobblestones were hand
cut to very specific dimensions and
indeed cobblestones are within this
range of 64 to 256 millimeters here is
another particle that is cobble in size
this is a piece of quartz and here's a
rounded metamorphic stone found on a
beach but again of cobble size and then
anything bigger than 256 is what we call
a boulder for instance we can see here
this large boulder obviously not the
largest Boulder but it does exceed 256
millimeters a large piece of Barton or
for mining and garnet okay the next
thing that we can do once we see that
these two sips are correspond to precise
sediment size classes is take a look at
the sand sizes which this sieve set is
primarily designed to be used we can see
that number 18 at one millimeter is very
coarse sand we can see that the number
35 will collect coarse sand we will see
that the number 60 at 0.25 millimeters
will collect medium sand 120 will
collect fine sand and the 230 meshes
sieve will collect very fine sands
anything that comes through the 230
Nashes sieve
passed through the boundary between sand
and mud and will be collected in the in
the pan mud of course if you can look at
your chart you'll see consists of two
size classes silt and clay and analysis
of silt and clay requires the use of
some other techniques by pipette or
hydrometer here for instance is a big
jar of mud from the Hudson River well
over 99.9% of this is all smaller than
sand so in the mud category silt and the
very finest particles which we call clay
okay
well we're ready to do what we would
call a qualitative analysis of a sand
that I have here most everyone even
without looking at this chart has a
feeling for what sand is you go to a
beach to sit on sand you don't go to the
beach to sit in the mud mud as it turns
out the particles are small enough to
fit into the pores of your skin so they
make you dirty sand rushes off easily
and it's comfortable on the other hand
you don't go to the beach to sit on
gravel unless you're into pain so I'm
pouring this sand in the top of this
sieve and we're now ready to do a
qualitative analysis of this sand now we
could have weighed the sand beforehand
in fact will demonstrate that to you
later
the really specific quantitative results
for this sand what just to demonstrate
the use of the sibs there are machines
that will shake these for an official
amount of time
in idea results move away some of these
particles and let's demonstrate the
results indeed we have some gravity
number 10 mesh sieve and if we look at
it we actually will find a particle here
that looks like it might be the smallest
the next the number 18 match to sieve
shows that we do have some very coarse
sand and indeed it has a very coarse
sand to it the next sieve number 35 mesh
shows you a significant quantity of
course and then we have medium sand on
the number 60 mesh sieve so far that
pile seems to be the biggest number 120
mesh sieve very fine sand significantly
smaller pile the very fine sand and even
smaller pile and if we look in the pan
there is a very small amount what we
would call mud so we can see from this
analysis that clearly 3/4 maybe even
more of the sand is coarse and medium
sand very small amount of gravel very
very small amount of mud the end member
is very fine sand and very coarse sand
in limited quantities so anyway this is
a demonstration of the sediment size
classes as generated by our set sibs
using these stainless steel wire meshes
with specific openings and millimeters
thanks see you again soon
you